my party's here hey how you doing get
I'm pretty sunburned [ __ ] amen
brother look at that well Marty an old
wires the Irish reppin that pink lobster
pneus I'm also Irish Peter Brown three
outside though you're playing that I
mom's name is Margot Jean Lestrange oh
Jesus that's the most Irish thing about
my nephew's name is Seamus Laroy Tracy
oh holy [ __ ] if I was cosplaying as an
Irish person that does the name I go for
hey Mike McCarty you're here to tell us
about gears of more yeah ultimate
edition so the final gears of war game
by the merriam-webster dictionary
it'sit's asked the remake of gears or
one how did you enjoy it young man I
thought it was a good remake um I think
it looks awesome obviously the cutscenes
are all redone they even added a few
things you get content that was on PC
that was never on console before yeah
pretty cool cause I wasn't good enough
to make it to the console yeah we never
got it before I never played the game on
PC so it's pretty great too I mean I
know what happens but it was great to
play it you know you get it's pretty
much inserted into act 5 yeah so still
ends when you're fighting um rom on the
train wow that's a great boss life we've
all known yeah Jesus that was especially
on like insane difficulty and beat all
those games are insane Wow co-op
sometimes how old you and give here's
war one came out here's more when i was
a freshman in high school 15 years old
oh [ __ ] so I was that was my my prime
Wow your prime now I'm waiting all
downhill from freshman year downhill now
I'm just an elderly 23 and so an office
has a new coat of paint it looks better
the 60 frames a second of multiplayer in
all out and mechanically does it still
feel like Gears of War one because that
game came out like it feels like an
entire era of video games has passed
since gears one came back because
everyone basically took what they did
and then iterate it on it so yeah does
it still feel okay to play yeah gears
were kind of like mark the pinnacle of
third-person shooting like cover base as
far as that goes and then you know like
you have so many people that came after
that but it feels it feels better and I
played 360 recently the Volder version
yeah and especially multiplayer having
60 frames per second is awesome I mean
just you know swiveling to aim at
someone just moving around the camera
itself doesn't really it's not as gritty
as it was and get
that you know campaign still feels the
same and that still feels great it's
kind of it's crazy that it's nine years
after and it still feels like it's one
of the better third person yeah those of
control like the first game because one
of the things that I remember playing
update a bit of this in Germany was I
wasn't sure if it felt actually like the
first game laws or if it if it's like
gears of war 3 Bush it movement but in
Gears of War one still like the same
scheme but it feels better definitely it
feels closer to two and three both of
which I think are better games in the
first game it also there are subtle
tweaks to the controls and whatnot on
you can't you can't do the down crawl
and multiplayer so if you get down and
multiply you guys okay you in like the
later games you can kind of get behind
cover wow I didn't realize that was
added effect yeah um I think it's in two
and three maybe just me but yeah it's
multiplayer is still great there's not
much to say about it just 60 frames they
edited boxes this map it's this really
small map it's just pretty much nasha
shotguns right I'm left and right which
is one thing about this game's
multiplayer that I didn't remember it
really falls back on the shot gun fights
yeah Mormons from behind those yeah and
you know in order to be good you kind of
have to master not really holding l2 aim
with a shotgun or if you're going to
just really quick like quick scope
almost and does that is that still
happening even early in because one of
the things about gears an online was
that the first two weeks were always
kind of a gimme it wasn't so bad I mean
after like ended week to start early
three everyone was just like doing a
roll and shotgun move and everyone was
like amazing at it is it is it difficult
or is it is the sort of an even playing
field moment well there those people
that really know how to snap between
cover cuz the good players will they
call it bouncing you think and they'll
just pretty much use the cover mechanic
to move instead of just actually walking
or dodging yeah throw there'll be people
like sweeping between cover and then
shooting during that those crazy and
then you know you see people pulling up
like double kills doing that and I'm not
that good used to play a lot but there
are definitely top tier players already
for sure I'm not one of them but try my
best it's a tough game to review Peter
your reviews editor for video games com
and when you're tackling a game like
this like how important do you think it
is that these games are kind of they
they fit what they were before like
they're just like I guess good like
remakes of the game as we know and love
or how important is that they're like
adding new features or like catching up
with the times in terms of graphics the
great thing about reviews is that
they're subjective right so I think
that's up to their person reviewing the
game to make that call you know it's a
game like Gears of War like you know
you've said a few times like you know
when it came out it was innovated the
things it did was we r interesting and
games have evolved a lot off of that
that base model for cover-based shooting
and and so now those things that used to
shine so bright are a little bit duller
and it's okay to say that like you know
if perception changes that's the way it
should be viewed but again if somebody
really loves that stuff and they don't
really care about other games that have
come since like if it doesn't replace
their love for this one and then that's
good for them I think ultimately it's
important that a game that's released
and reviewed is reviewed by the person
reviewing it the way they see it and
there's there's no right answer here I
find a telling that I guess of the sort
of overall body proposition because I'm
like I'm a big ears were fine i love all
the game while the apartment judgment
that was a bit of a train wreck and
nobody gives a [ __ ] about Bard but like
Baird but I've already mispronounced
somebody's name a lot in a video this
week I want to do it again there to tell
for I think Kickstarter's yes yeah
exactly and the apartment like even so
I'm not really that excited about
playing this like how much do you think
the fact that there they've like done
the 60 frames a second of multiplayer
and how much the fact that they're
adding all this like free stuff like if
you buy this game before december 31st
you play it before december if you play
it right so even if you get about your
buddy worded it so i don't go you could
play it and not necessarily own it
yourself but if you have you basically
get the backwards compatibility f
unlocked on xbox live whenever that
stuff goes properly live at a beta for
all the games Gears of War One the whole
way through judgment and all I want to
be clear here are you saying it unlocks
the ability to play those games or you
unlock those games you unlock those
games okay yeah yeah cuz that's very
different than what you said yeah yeah
they'll be available you only get the
chance to play it yeah now how much how
important do you think that is to the
overall value proposition for the
package I think if you're a Gears war
fan this is a great way to get back into
it before coalition releases for
especially because going back to Gears
of War one one of the positive things
about the campaign that I
it was much more intimate and personal
the characters are pretty they're kind
of static there's a few time like you
know later on you had mentioned earlier
Dom has to shoot his wife and yeah
here's where to what it does yeah then
three comes along and I think they made
more of a consolidated effort to
actually characterize these people
instead of making them vehicles for the
action even onions in it yeah Nadia
plays a big part oh yeah and I think
that it's a good segue for the coalition
I know they went back to it to try to
figure out what makes a Gears game what
can we do well for 4 with this and I
know the gears were for one of the big
things are touting is they want to make
it more horror driven and more intimate
personal the e3 demo they showed it was
kind of really dark I mean all the gears
games or dark but it was so darkly dark
it was a darkest demo I've ever seen in
my goddamn life yes like what is going
on yeah and there's that monster chasing
him on the rooftops and I know that you
know rod fergusson was always saying
that this is like his team's training
camp for years war or and also yeah the
value of its forty dollars just for a
remaster that alone I think is good
value because if you're a Gears fan it's
worth going back to I'm a big years fan
as well but to get two three and
judgment I actually kind of like
judgment I like the arcade they kind of
twist they put on it two or three months
I think three is my favorite Campaign
wise I won't defend myself show judge me
today yeah but um another the flipside
of returning to a game that's nine years
old as I found I forgot how much of the
campaign revolved around going into an
area killing about ten locusts Oh more
15 and when you hear a gong sound you're
like oh I'm gonna move to the next area
pick up a few frag grenades pick up some
ammo hopefully find a power weapon
there's a sniper rifle which unless
you're on hard corner dawn is a
satellite working yeah I can use it here
yeah a great part the berserkers one of
those few like flashes of brilliance i
still really enjoyed but come Act two
out of five now yeah I was just really
it became a slog later on because I was
just I mean a lot of shooters have that
you know it's kill a certain amount
people to get through the you know gated
progrock needs time to open the door
yeah justifications are you just they
introduce horde mode like in disguise
before two came out yeah yeah exactly
but there are so many times and like I
think the assumption on maybe not the
assumption but I expected it going in to
just be a better version of the 2006
yeah
60 release but there are a few times
after having played the 360 version
recently about two acts to the campaign
I encountered problems in remaster that
I didn't in the first one oh really yeah
it was a few times like these games are
better played cooperatively like yes
which I'd you know split screen was
still my favorite way to play and you
can do as well checkers if you could you
drop and drop out whenever you want cool
so like my friend had you know dropped
in he was dumb and he was much more
welcome than the AI don because AI is
still frustrating um there's that part
in act 2 where you're avoiding the
shadows and trying to shoot propane tank
piece of krill away from just shredding
you and it's a cool part you're playing
co-op it can be kind of frustrating but
it's really frustrating when Don just
keeps like heroically running into the
shadows and then you hear the frill you
hear the krill just tear them off you
see his down symbol yeah like okay I can
either just go forward kill all these
guys by myself which on hardcore is a
little harder sometimes they I helps you
know but I've always played those games
on hardcourts I think it's like the
heroic and in Halo it's kind of a good
balance between kind of easy and like
really hard yeah challenging and a good
one right it it's like a good it's
perfectly paced I think as far as
playing in that difficulty but there are
too many times we're done we have
footage I think of the Dom just standing
there in front of a turret and and then
I'd you know revive him jump back he
would stand there again it happened four
times and I was showing um so I told
someone over my desk to show him is like
is this just like me or is this not
supposed to happen no that's kind of
funny but yeah and I had a fun time with
a game I think it was a good remaster of
a game that hasn't aged just as well as
I thought I would you know they're also
part times later when Dom just wouldn't
like I remember I was standing it's in
Act five and you're on top of this
essentially like a stage set at a play
and you take down this wall to cover up
where the cedar is shooting out the unit
you know the Nemesis enemies those
floating ones and Dom is supposed to go
up a turn of valve which moves you along
the catwalk yes I remember yeah and I
kept pressing lb to see what Dom wasn't
see what my objective was and it was
just Marcus saying Dom the stage she
waiting Dom I think you said it six
times because I was thinking maybe
there's an enemy that he's killing and
hasn't killed yet yeah but then I
finally found him like you know if you
hold I'll be it'll show him or anybody
he's just sitting behind cover and then
if Mark is dumb this stage and then
finally I just
load the checkpoint and that was one of
six times it happened oh [ __ ] where they
minded okay sounds like the AI is even a
little bit rougher than it was for some
right yeah where sometimes the cutscenes
just wouldn't trigger when I killed
everybody you would hear that Gong you
know go to where the cutscenes poster
here because I have a pretty good memory
of the game I was like oh I'm just going
toward marks the mansion his new house
anyone get in rigor so like okay I think
maybe I did something wrong or miss
someone I'm gonna reload it see if I
just kill him faster get [ __ ] Mike up
top of me and I did it and it didn't
work and then i reloaded of like I
really i think i'm just missing somebody
and then i finally got to the point
where i walked up the same area and then
it cut to the cutscene which is a
gorgeous cutscene or just took a while
to get there Wow all right a little bit
rough around the edges as we remember it
maybe or maybe a little bit worse like
my hearty thank you so much come on tell
us all about gears of war Ultimate
Edition and what score did you give it a
seven seven out of ten read that review
on going like it got like in eight a few
years I kinda got in my way six so i can
only an eight this looks better ah I
know I just I really just wanted to
stick it to them and I got cliff what
you're making your own thing yeah you
guys all want to talk about we'll talk
about that later yeah I packs i'll see
you at pax you're gonna pack some point
you're not gonna like you're gonna pay
Medicare solid for next god damn five
months yeah yeah son of a [ __ ] rest of
us have to wait damn i have to weigh
like a few extra days on staying seattle
just for a while Oh Mike's got a whole
day calm million vacation poor guy Tina
sounders game are you seahawks preseason
though I'm just gonna be up there for
work slaw Seattle sander is a supplier
what's a sander those ship or something
oh it's they just took the name of a
body of water and edit yards oh yeah
it's called the samp you did it sound
yes and they're gonna build a bridge
across the Puget Sound made of aircraft
carriers see that [ __ ] that's the only
thing I'm worried that is this is
fallout that is that's some [ __ ] raid
[ __ ] that's like something hid software
would come up with yeah except they
wouldn't put water in the game because
it would have taken too many mega
textures that's the longer this week
thanks so much Peter Brad for hanging
there
you